[Music]
Jessica it's so nice to have you here
with us today thank you it's nice being
here so you're one of the top tennis
players in the world but you're also
have a reputation as a bit of a late
bloomer so yeah four years ago when you
were ranked outside the top 100 did you
ever think you'd be where you are today
probably not to be honest I mean I
always thought that I would make it
happen but at the same time putting in
all the work and then looking back four
years later about where my mindset was I
don't know if I really truly believed it
so yeah it's I I did but I didn't I
don't know it's it's just been a very
long journey I guess so earlier in your
career you dealt with a couple of
serious injuries that sidelined you for
for pretty long stretches what kept you
going through what must have been
difficult rehabs there I think it was
just like my love for the game would
always kind of come through and I would
have these tough weeks in rehab and I
would seem to always be able to get
through them or bounce back and I think
I just wanted to get healthy and give
myself a chance to really prove you know
what I could do and not for other people
but I think more just for myself and I
you know knew I was right there I
practiced with a lot of the same girls
and you see them watching them on TV
having great results and you're sitting
there injured and hurt and I think that
always kind of motivated me as well to
to give myself a chance to to come back
and be stronger and see what I could do
so I think that was a big motivation and
then just the passion you know that I
love to play the sport always kept me
going and I think that's important it
gets tough if you don't love the sport
so I think that's what always kind of
got me coming back
what do you love about tennis I don't
know it's just I love the individuality
of it I love that it's all on you and I
take a lot of pride in knowing that not
a lot of sports are like that so to me
it's really fun to be able to say you
know I'm an individual athlete no I I
don't I can't really talk to my coach I
can't really talk strategy you know in
really tough moments it's only you and I
think that's what makes tennis so unique
and special it sucks when you lose cuz
it's all on you but when you win you
know you're the one that got yourself
through a really tough moment or a tough
match and that to me is like the best
[Music]
feeling you're coming into your own at
this interesting time with Serena
Williams retired and a bunch of young
American players on the rise do you
sense an opportunity there for you I
mean yeah I feel like I've already had
opportunities as well but for the next
few years definitely I I mean it's tough
obviously it's in I think a tough period
where even though there's not the Serena
and venuses of the world there's still
some really good players and a lot of
depth I mean we saw Coco golf take
advantage of that at the US Open really
get hot this summer and and prove that
you know she could be a slam Champion so
I think that definitely motivates me as
well I think there's a lot of
opportunity right now for a lot of girls
so me being one of them so hopefully I
can you know take advantage of
that I think a lot of casual tennis fans
maybe don't realize that outside of the
four majors there's still a gender pay
Gap in tennis and I know it can be tough
to get women's matches televised in
prime time I know that's something that
you've spoken about in the past so how
do you feel the effort is going to
change that and you know what are your
sort of thoughts on the tennis landscape
right now yeah it's crazy time you know
women's tennis is a huge sport for the
highest paid female athlete but at the
same time that the pay Gap is still very
big and we always talk about how it's
equal at slams but those are four
tournaments a year it's not equal at a
lot of the other tournaments I think we
need to do better at marketing our game
which hopefully I think the WTA just
started a new partnership with a private
Equity company that's going to come in
and kind of take the commercial side and
hopefully really revamp the marketing
and I think getting more stories out
there on all the incredible players that
we
have we can make this the last question
so I'll make it a tough one what do you
want your legacy to be ooh I would love
to just know that I helped the game I
think helped kids especially I love
tennis and I think it's created so many
opportunities even just sitting here
today the opportunities that it's
created for me it's it's insane and then
on top of that you know change the game
and hopefully leave a mark not just
results wise but you know whether it's
helping us get to equal pay or helping
more kids get rackets in their hands I
think any of those things would be
amazing and I want to you know give back
to the sport as much as I
[Music]
can